- [Voiceover] In another video
we've already talked about
what an opposite of a number is,
but we'll review it a little bit.
If we start with a positive number,
say, the number four.
If you have a number
and then we want to think about
what the opposite of that number is.
Opposite.
This is just the symbol for number
or shorthand for number.
So if the number is four,
what is its opposite?
Well, four is one, two, three, four
to the right of zero.
Positive four is four
So its opposite is going to be
one, two, three, four to the left.
So it's going to be negative four.
Or another way to think about it,
if you have a positive number,
its opposite is going to be
the negative of that number.
So another way of thinking about it is,
is that this negative
literally means opposite.
One way to think about
it, this is the number
that is the opposite of four.
So let me write this down.
So if I write negative four.
Negative, let me write this,
negative four.
That literally means...
So you can take this negative symbol
as meaning opposite.
Opposite.
Opposite of four. Opposite of four.
If you were to say negative,
instead of saying a specific number
let's just say a letter that
could represent a number.
So if I said negative A,
that means the opposite of the number A.
That means the opposite...
Opposite of...
Let me do that in blue color.
Opposite of A. Of A.
And if this confuses you
a little bit just look,
A could be any number right over here.
So let me draw a number line
just so this can be a little bit,
make a little bit more sense hopefully.
So this is a number line.
Let me put some tick marks here.
I don't know much each
of these tick marks jump
but let's say that A is some
number that is right over here.
Well negative A is going
to be the opposite of A.
So if A is three tick marks to the right
negative A is going to be
three tick marks to the left.
One, two, three.
And so the opposite of A
is going to be this value right over here.
And we can write that, we can
write opposite of A over here.
We could literally write opposite,
opposite of A
is that number right over there.
Or as a shorthand, we can just write--
We can just write negative.
We can just write this is
negative A right over here.
Negative A.
So with that in mind,
if we literally view this negative symbol
as meaning the opposite
of whatever this is,
let's try something interesting.
What would be the negative--
Let me do this in another color.
What would be the negative of
negative three?
And I encourage you to pause
the video and think about it.
Well we just said, this
negative means the opposite.
So you can think about this as meaning
this means the opposite...
Opposite of negative--
The opposite of negative three.
So what is the opposite of negative three?
Well negative three is
three to the left of zero.
One, two, three.
So it's opposite is going to
be three to the right of zero.
One, two, three.
So it's going to be positive three.
So this is equal to positive three.
Or we could just write positive three
like that.
So hopefully this gives
you a better appreciation
for what opposite means
and also how it relates to the
actual negative symbol.
We could keep going.
We could do something like
what is the negative
of the negative
of negative--
Let me do a different
number. Of negative two.
Well, this part right over here
the negative, the
opposite of negative two,
which is really the opposite
of the opposite of two,
well that's just going to be two.
Every time you say opposite
you flip over the number line.
So this flips you over the
number line two to the left
and this flips you back two to the right
so all of this is going to be two
but then you're going to
take the opposite of two
so that's just going to be negative two.
If you threw another
negative in front of this,
it would be the opposite of all of this.
So it would be the
opposite of negative two
and then all of a sudden
it would become positive.
So every time you put that
negative in front there
you're flipping on the other
side of the number line.